[Music]
on this monday night canada's first
pandemic budget
and your bottom line ottawa's
multi-billion dollar blueprint for an
economic recovery the emergency benefits
being extended
and for how long plus the promise of 10
a day daycare
we will get it done the focus on a
greener economy
and what's not in this budget plus my
one-on-one with deputy prime minister
and finance minister christian freeland
who's now eligible for the oxford
astrazeneca covid vaccine
the province is lowering the age limit
and a giant leap for scientists this
must have been how the
wright brothers felt the little
helicopter making an
astronomical ascent into the history
books
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
canada's first pandemic budget is out
and it is chock full of billions in new
spending
nearly 50 billion dollars just in 2021
spread among parents
seniors students and small business
owners there are billions to extend
emergency pandemic benefit measures
that many canadians and businesses are
still relying on
the finance minister christie freeland
calls it a smart responsible ambitious
plan for jobs and growth
as the first female finance minister in
canada she had said her role as a woman
and a mother
would inform her plans for the country
and the single biggest financial
commitment
is for a national child care program
promising ten dollars a day
daycare across the country within five
years
there's also a promise of a luxury tax
the spending will
drive the deficit up for the fiscal year
just ended
the federal deficit is expected to be
about 354 billion dollars
and that will push the national debt
past the one trillion dollar mark
for the first time our chief political
correspondent david aiken has been
studying the budget's
700 plus pages all day he joins us now
david
what are the other big takeaways
well donna this is a budget for the
pandemic and beyond it is
700 pages and then some thick
stuffed with brand new spending
proposals 50 billion dollars in spending
and it's stuffed with aspirations in
case the liberals
want to use this as a campaign document
in a general election
the centerpiece of the first budget ever
presented by a woman
is a commitment to build a national
child care plan
this time we're going to do it
this budget is the map and the trailhead
but it will not be
cheap or quick it will cost 30 billion
dollars over the next five years
and will require significant
negotiations with the provinces
that's the biggest single spending
commitment but there are plenty more
for example three billion dollars to
improve long-term care homes
17.6 billion for so-called green
recovery initiatives
and a new investment of 18 billion
dollars to improve health and
economic development in indigenous
communities
on top of that the canada emergency wage
subsidy
and the canada emergency rent subsidy
will be extended until the end of
september
something new for business a canada
recovery hiring program
that will start in june this will be a
subsidy paid to employers
who add people to their payroll the
budget also establishes a minimum wage
for federally regulated companies of
fifteen dollars an hour
all of this will push the debt to gdp
ratio from
pre-pandemic levels of about thirty
percent to more than
fifty percent this year and it will stay
around fifty percent
for at least the next five years the
question is are we fiscally sustainable
we are but there's a big but that also
makes assumptions that things like
interest rates will not change
significantly in the
in the medium term so now to the
politics of this budget because of
course
this is a liberal minority government
and the liberals will need at least
one other party to support this budget
and to avoid triggering
a general election this spring donna
okay david aiken in ottawa thank you
there have been multiple calls and
promises for a national child care
program one that would be affordable
accessible and high quality it is
crucial to getting women back into the
workforce
now as abigail beeman reports christie
freeland thinks she is the finance
minister who can deliver it making
affordable child care a reality
at ten dollars a day
she's eight months old and amaya's
parents have been searching for child
care
her whole life her mom starts a new job
next month
she's on multiple waitlists right now
and nothing has really come through
tough to find and to pay for definitely
we'll have to compromise on a lot many
more things if we want the best care
toronto has the highest child care fees
in the country
more than 70 dollars a day for a toddler
edmonton is around the middle
around 44 dollars a day quebec offers
the cheapest
less than 10 dollars sometimes it even
makes me want to think about not going
back to work and just
staying back and caring for her but i
think about the impact it has on
what she think about me if her dog if
her mother being such a qualified person
just gave up and sat back at home
speaking as your finance minister and
as a working mother we will get it
done christopher freeland was two years
old when child care was first declared
imperative to women's equality
50 years later during a pandemic that's
exacerbated the problem
the country's first woman finance
minister promises to do what no federal
government could in half a century
high quality early learning and child
care
for an average of 10 dollars a day
a 50 cut in fees by next year and
child care for 10 a day by 2026.
to make it happen the liberals plan to
spend 30 billion
over the next five years eventually a
permanent annual commitment of 8.3
billion
9.2 if you count previous promises
if this is something that survives the
next election it could be truly
transformative for the sector
the liberals are proposing to split
child care fees with the province's
50-50 in order
to make this happen but that will
involve more negotiations and for
cash-strapped provinces which don't
already heavily invest in child care
there's no guarantee they'll sign on
abigail beeman global news
ottawa earlier this afternoon i spoke
with the finance minister and asked her
about that 354 billion
deficit how much does she worry about
paying it off
um so donna i worry about
everything i think that's my job as
finance minister
um that 354 billion dollar deficit
from last year 2020 2021
actually is lower than what we forecast
we forecast
381.6 billion
so you know that is
serious but i think it's important to
point out to canadians that it's less
than we
provisioned for i think the other thing
i would really point out
is our spending is necessary
and it's also reasonable and sustainable
over the five years that this budget
forecasts we have
a declining debt to gdp ratio we have
at the end of the forecast horizon
that's 25
26 we have debt to gdp going down
to 49.2
and we have a deficit of 1.1 percent
so you know this is the deepest
recession
since the great depression it has cost
money to support canadians and canadian
businesses to get through
it but we can afford it this is
sustainable
and we're going to come roaring back
okay let's talk about child care
promises as you know about some kind of
national child care program have been
made for years
yours is the biggest and i know that it
is vital to getting women back into the
workforce
you need to win the next election and
work with the provinces to implement
this
so should parents expect 10 a day
daycare anytime soon
yeah they should expect it five years
from now that's what we promised
that is what we're going to deliver and
you know donna i do not underestimate
how hard this is how complicated
it is uh or how much money it costs
but i think it is absolutely essential
it's essential for families like the
really nice family that you showed a
minute ago on your show
so it's essential for people's lives but
you know what
we really need this to drive economic
growth
if and i'm going to say when we get a
universal
early learning and child care system
built across our country
it is going to have the biggest impact
on the canadian economy
since nafta i did have another question
unfortunately we lost the line
to the finance minister
the liberal government sees the
post-pandemic recovery as a pivot point
towards a greener economy
among the government's budget proposals
80 million dollars toward a net zero
economy including
clean technologies and reducing
emissions a 115 million dollar climate
plan including help for agriculture
90 million dollars for interest-free
loans for home retrofits and
605 million dollars to protect nature
lands lakes and oceans
as eric sorensen reports there is one
region of canada that is watching the
green transition with trepidation
the oil patch the aim is to reduce the
impact of greenhouse gases across the
country
with incentives to decarbonize big
emitters like steel companies
interest-free loans for homeowners to
make houses more energy efficient
and funding to mitigate against
disasters like flooding and wildfires
but if there is one sector that faces
the greatest disruption and loss of jobs
it is the western oil economy td
economics calculates three quarters of
oil sector jobs could be displaced by
twenty fifty
ottawa will provide 55 million dollars
over three years for skills training and
workforce planning
part of which will support a transition
for workers in transforming sectors like
energy
we do owe them an ability to transition
to what the next way of bringing energy
forward is going to be
jim sandercock chairs the alternative
energy program at the northern alberta
institute of technology
alberta has vast amounts of solar and
wind potential
and the alternative energy program is
already expanding its training
for jobs in greener energy this is a
fantastic wealth creation opportunity as
we're
changing our energy systems over to
something that has a lower carbon
footprint
is less polluting ottawa will put 20
million dollars towards carbon capture
and storage technology this year
technology that oil companies themselves
have advanced
the aim is to increase carbon capture in
canada from 4 megatons a year to 15
megatons
but a big piece of that will be tax
incentives for which there is no costing
laid out
it will depend on provincial
participation we still depend very
significantly on oil and gas to satisfy
primary energy demand
and the likelihood that we'll still need
oil and gas to play a role is quite
significant so technologies like carbon
capture are actually going to be really
important in lowering the emissions
intensity of the sector overall
ottawa is proposing almost 18 billion
dollars in its green recovery
and is promising a more ambitious
climate target this week
when the prime minister takes part in a
virtual leaders summit on climate
hosted by u.s president joe biden on
thursday
earth day eric sorensen global news
toronto
well today's budget is about fiscal
priorities and plans but it is also a
political document and it's widely seen
as a pre-election platform for the
liberals
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson is with me mercedes does this
strike you as the
pre-election platform that a lot of
people speculate it is
well it's certainly a document the
liberals are ready to fight an election
on but i don't think it's one that they
want to right now and frankly donna i
don't think it's one
that the opposition want to fight an
election on at this moment either
in a minority government situation we
typically be talking about the fact that
the government could come down when this
goes to a vote
but there's no poison pill in this and
with the third wave what it is
especially in places like ontario that
seems unlikely but that doesn't mean
that the opposition is going to be happy
with what's in here
or that there's not going to be some
negotiations behind closed doors
conservative leader aaron o'toole spoke
this afternoon he's not pleased with
what's in the budget
here's what he had to say well it seems
there is no fiscal
anchor in this plan it's almost like a
floating anchor
uh all depending on a massive debt
and no clear plan to actually see
economic
growth now on the other hand jug meat
singh is questioning where pharmacare
and universal basic
income are all of this though at the end
of the day donna really
not the budget the liberals had
initially wanted not a transformative
one
because that third wave just focused
them to really refocus
on the pandemic it is not over mercedes
stevenson in ottawa thank you
more changes to the guidelines about the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine coming up who
is now being told they are eligible for
it
police checkpoints are now set up along
ontario's borders with quebec and
manitoba the province is restricting all
non-essential travel to try to limit the
spread of covet 19
only those driving across for work
medical care transportation of goods or
exercising their indigenous treaty
rights are being allowed through
and prince edward island is banning all
non-resident travel from outside
atlantic canada until may 17th
the island reported three new covet
infections today all related to travel
from outside the region
rotational workers and commercial
truckers who arrive will need to isolate
until their first negative test
even if they are vaccinated and british
colombia is bringing in new travel
measures too
starting on friday premier horgan says
police will be able to do random
roadside checks across the province
to make sure people aren't traveling
outside their local health region
unnecessarily they will be susceptible
to all travelers not just a few
travelers
and again they will be random and there
will be a fine if you are traveling
outside of your area
without a legitimate reason the premier
says the province will also
put up signs along the alberta border
asking non-residents to stay out if they
don't have an essential reason
to travel several canadian provinces
have expanded access to the astrazeneca
vaccine
this week people over the age of 40 are
eligible in bc
alberta manitoba and ontario a health
canada review recently found the vaccine
safe for all canadians
the national advisory committee on
immunization though still recommends
astrazeneca not be given to anyone under
the age of 55 though
that guidance could change too heather
urix west
explains when brent causey turned 40
last month he never imagined he'd be
eligible for the covet 19 vaccine
so soon i was thinking probably at the
earliest in june
um i that's kind of thing they said that
they'd have you know 70 percent kind of
vaccinated by the energy and i thought
it'd be kind of in that last
cohort almost to go through instead he
along with all albertans over the age of
40 can book appointments for the
astrazeneca vaccine starting tuesday
alberta's premier made the announcement
via twitter the decision is based on
growing scientific knowledge about the
vaccine and is based on the advice from
alberta's chief
medical officer of health ontario was
the first province to make the change
after alberta bc and manitoba followed
too
this is largely based on on risk
assessments benefit
risk assessments and so if we look at
the
uh what we've learned more and more
about
the the blood clot issue with
astrazeneca
how rare it is and how what the risk
of transmission of covet is the benefit
far outweighs the risk among the
previously eligible age cohort of 55 to
64
there does appear to have been some
hesitancy associated with the
astrazeneca vaccine
but this ottawa family doctor says her
patients are now clamoring to get
whatever vaccine they can
particularly as infection numbers rise
it was absolutely um
exciting to know that we would be able
to immunize more of these younger
patients
and also it was a bit frustrating that
the decision was made that 40 would be
the cut off as opposed to
younger groups because like i said we
have many people who are in their
20s and 30s who are also forced to work
outside the home
brent cossey shares this frustration too
knowing his wife who works as a teacher
is just a little too young to access the
vaccine
in alberta right now heather urex west
global news
calgary nearly 4 million vaccine doses
have now been administered in ontario
mobile clinics are being set up in some
of that province's hot spots
residents in targeted postal codes lined
up overnight to get their job at some
pop-up clinics
over 5000 doses have been administered
to people 18
and over in communities with higher than
average transmission levels
ontario recorded more than 4 000 new
coveted cases today
the sixth day in a row the number has
been that high
hospitalizations and icu levels have
also hit another high
there are now 755 critical care patients
in ontario
516 of them are on ventilators
ahead derrick chauvin's trial the
closing arguments over his hand
in george floyd's death
the 12 jurors in the trial of derek
shoven have now begun deliberations in
minneapolis
the former police officer is charged
with murdering george floyd
in closing arguments today the
prosecution said chauvin betrayed the
badge and everything it stood for
when he pressed his knee on floyd's neck
for more than nine minutes during the
arrest last may
the 46-year-old black man gasped for air
and pleaded for his life
chauvin's defense attorney asked the
jury to reflect on the knowledge and
actions of what he called a
reasonable police officer in a
use-of-force situation
with a crowd of bystanders chauvin is
charged with second-degree murder
third-degree murder and second-degree
manslaughter
the jury will have to decide whether
chauvin's actions played a significant
role
in floyd's death russian officials say
they have transferred alexi navalny to a
prison hospital
his supporters fear the russian
opposition leader is extremely ill and
could die
at any moment the 44 year old is nearly
three weeks into a hunger strike to
protest the refusal by russian
authorities
to allow his own doctors to visit him
prison authorities claim navalny has
consented to vitamin
therapy they say he is in satisfactory
condition
navalny's personal doctors believe he is
at risk of
heart or kidney failure and that he
could be near death he's serving
a two and a half year sentence
first flight up next ingenuity takes off
from the red planet
you're watching global national
[Music]
it's really just a short flight for a
little helicopter 39 seconds in fact but
because it happened on mars today it is
a huge leap for humankind
nasa's ingenuity helicopter made history
mike charley looks at how it happened
and what it means for our ambitions on
the red planet
oh the weight must have been
excruciating at 3 34 am the ingenuity
helicopter was told to fly
and for more than three hours nasa
scientists waited for the satellites to
line up
so the data could stream back to earth
altimeter data
confirmed that ingenuity has performed
its first flight
the first flight of a powered aircraft
to another planet
for posterity's sake this is the first
picture taken by ingenuity in the air
the rover perseverance was the only
witness to the short flight
which had been delayed twice because of
technical issues
when things work it looks easy i would
like to take this
opportunity to remind how difficult it
is to fly a rotorcraft at mars
now that they've proven it works
scientists like mcgill's richard levaye
are eager to see what it can do for
actual science
like investigating subsurface lava tubes
they believe
exist on mars and the moon this opens up
new ideas for missions now we're not
only uh
stuck with proposing you know where can
a rover go we can start dreaming up
these crazy ideas that will maybe one
day become a true mission
for now nasa's finest deserve a moment
to exhale
before firing up ingenuity for another
flight
microlight global news toronto and that
is global national for this monday i'm
donna friesen we want to leave you with
something to aspire to something people
in australia and new zealand are now
able to do
remember airport hugs
hugs and kisses the first in more than a
year people in australia and new zealand
can do this again because they've formed
a quarantine free travel bubble
it looks like the end of the movie love
actually but i swear it's not
kind of gives you the same feeling
though thanks for watching hope to see
you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye